foreign  news now investigators first to report a  Nevada state senator's son accused of  shooting a family member inside the  mayoral's candidate's home previously  shot at a person through a wall police  call it an unreported incident  Democratic State Senate senator Pat  spearman's 21-year-old son faces  attempted murder charges connected to  last Thursday's shooting police say he  was blowing marijuana smoke in a  five-year-old's face when the man he  shot told him to stop Osborne previously  faced a gun related charge but the case  was dismissed a judge though had ordered  him to Forfeit his weapon now police say  a surge of spearman's Home found a gun a  handgun in Osborne's closet